immigration the issue that's dogged
successive conservative governments
today hitting a new record high over 600
000 net arrivals last year giving this
government a very big political problem
indeed net migration to the United
Kingdom is far too high under the
points-based system we introduced
post-brexit we can control immigration
we must control immigration and we will
the right wing of the party running out
of patience the anger and frustration of
my uh constituents is have been focused
on illegal migration up until now but
that anger and frustration will grow
when they consider these legal migration
figures some people in the treasury seem
to think that a good way to grow the
economy is to fill the country up with
more and more people
but this is bad for productivity and bad
for British workers who are being
undercut by mass migration from all over
the world immigration is the home
secretary's brief Under Pressure
swerving questions Home Secretary are
you failing to get immigration down are
we losing control of UK borders
labor quick to attack but refusing to
set targets of its own I would expect
that migration figures to come down for
things these really unusually high
levels they are of course I think twice
the level that ministers were aiming for
so that is part of the chaos really that
we've got in the home office and this
continual a massive gap between the
rhetoric from conservative ministers and
the reality in 2019 the Tories promised
to cut net migration to below quarter of
a million it's now more than double that
so this isn't just about illegal Small
Boat Crossings legal migration has
become a huge political problem for the
Prime Minister too and there are no easy
solutions as Rishi sunak tries to
balance the needs of the economy with
voter anger and frustration that
immigration has got so high all of which
the conservatives fear they'll be
punished for at the next general
election
one man they still fear on the sidelines
hinting a comeback Parliament and the
government have ignored the will of the
people they've ignored what was said in
that brexit referendum and so now
a bigger question emerges as to how
we're going to change politics Take Back
Control stop the boats
slogans are easy the delivery anything
but and the pressure now really on Beth
Rigby Sky News Westminster